[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben möchtet ihr eure gäste
oder eure familie beeindruckend da macht
diesen nutella baum nach der geht's
super schnell und ist supereinfach dafür
brauchen wir auch gar nicht so viele
zutaten und zwar sind das zwei packungen
blätterteig 300 gramm nutella ein eigelb
und ein essen für milch
[Musik]
ich bereite mir meine erste ladung
blätterteig jetzt erst mal auf einem
backblech aus
[Musik]
und darauf verstreiche ich dann
gleichmäßig dass nutella
[Musik]
und dann gebe ich die zweite paarung
bester tag darüber
anschließend wird daraus eine tannenbaum
form ausgeschnitten
[Musik]
und die reste bitte bloß nicht
wegschmeißen die kann man ebenfalls
backen und dann selber vernaschen
[Musik]
danach müssen nur noch auf beiden seiten
waagerechte streifen eingeschnitten
werden aber bitte nicht ganz zur mitte
die mitte muss unbedingt frei bleiben
[Musik]
und jetzt werden die stränge nach außen
gezwirbelt
dann noch das eigelb mit der milch
vermischen und mit einem pinsel über den
baum verstreichen
[Musik]
und den gebe ich jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 220 grad ober
und unterhitze für ca 18 minuten
[Musik]
und schon ist der leckere weihnachtsbaum
fertig ich gebe da noch etwas
puderzucker drauf nachdem er abgekühlt
ist und dann sehe ich ihn die
viel spaß beim nachbacken und falls sie
mehr davon sehen wollt dann dürft ihr
mich natürlich gerne abonnieren bis zum
nächsten mal auf welches kitchen